[Musique]
décontracté serein calme
c'est à dire à part of entrevoit le
chemin de la victoire
l'ancien prisonnier libéré par ses
supporters il ya trois mois après des
manifestations historiques voient
désormais grand pour son pays et ses six
millions d'habitants bureaucratie et
corruption tout cela empoisonne la vie
de notre peuple mais nous vivons dans un
beau pays nous pouvons et devons bien
vivre je ne vais pas mentir et
promettent que tout peut être résolu en
un an
c'est impossible et vous le savez bien
mais nous devons commencer à travailler
dans ce sens octobre 2020 des élections
législatives contestés par les opposants
du président se renie by dave hancock
qui évoque l'achat de votes plonge le
pays dans une nouvelle crise politique
la capitale bichkek devient alors le
théâtre d'affrontements avec les forces
de l'ordre
[Applaudissements]
à
manifestation qui rime avec libération
les contestataires profit du chaos
ambiant pour sortir de leur cellule
l'ancien président atambaïev et c'est
dire jafarov le premier arrêté de
nouveau quelques jours plus tard le
second bien plus soutenu populaire voit
son destin basculer plaidant son
innocence sa condamnation en 2017 en
onze ans et demi de prison pour
l'enlèvement d'un gouverneur est annulée
par un tribunal
sous pression le président jupp heynckes
démissionne c'est à dire jafarov
accèdent dans la foulée aux fonctions de
chef de l'état avant de démissionner en
novembre afin de pouvoir se présenter à
la présidentielle
favori des sondages saparov est porteur
d'une révision de la constitution qui
fait débat ces derniers mois si elle est
acceptée le chef de l'état et lui
s'occupera désormais de nommer son
gouvernement un pouvoir enlever au
parlement
le futur président pourrait aussi
briguer pour la première fois dans
l'histoire un second mandat et les
kirghizs appelé à un référendum
ce dimanche de chaque mois tu sais toute
constitution est un nouveau projet qui
est maintenant proposée est là un
objectif très simple poussée les
personnes instruites hors du pays ne
laisser dans le pays que les personnes
qui accepteront tout sans aucun esprit
critique vis-à-vis du pouvoir soutenir
le kanak se tenir le califat c'est à
dire a part of utilise sa position et
son statut pour plonger les gens dans le
chaos
ça ne devrait pas être comme ça ne tient
pas compte des personnes il n'a même pas
assisté aux débats depuis son
indépendance en 1991 le kirghizstan a vu
trois de ses cinq anciens présidents
être renversé par des révolutions
populaires